It's president's week here on the Rubin
report working with learn liberty to
bring you five shows in five days on
five different presidents of the United
States.
And joining me today is professor of
history and economics at San Jose State
University and author of the book
emancipating the slaves and slaving free
men,
a history of the American civil war,
Jeffrey Rogers.
Humble.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
It's a pleasure to be on the Rubin
report.
We have already just in the few minutes
we've been sitting here,
we talked about almost every other
prison right now.
I guess we're going to have to get to
this Lincoln guy.
Yes,
definitely.
Let's do it.
So first off,
the obvious question,
was he actually a vampire hunter?
Uh,
I doubt it.
It's not a show that I watched was a
movie.
I forgot it was a movie.
I thought it was a documentary,
but apparently not.
All right.
There's a lot I want to talk to you now.
It was obvious when we were selecting
our five presidents to do this week,
we wanted to do some of some of the big
ones and some smaller ones.
And hopefully we'll do this for many
years to come and get to everybody.
But Lincoln was the one I was like,
all right,
we got to do it because I think if you
polled most Americans,
they always say that Lincoln is their
favorite.
I think probably George Washington comes
in second,
but I think Lincoln is the big one.
Um,
so I want to do a little bit on his bio
then I want to do obviously on the
political stuff and civil war and
freeing the slaves.
And I want to talk about some of the
interesting criticisms that you have of
him in this book.
Uh,
but first let's just start a little bit
about
childhood.
Where should we start a.
well,
Lincoln was born in Kentucky,
a 18.
Oh,
nine.
Um,
and grew up in a,
in a very poor frontier household.
Uh,
his mother died when he was very young.
It was partly raised by,
uh,
by a stepmother.
They moved to Indiana and basically,
um,
he educated himself,
uh,
and um,
and it was a humble background as he
would have,
as he,
as he described it himself.
How is that possible to educate himself?
Back then,
I mean,
it was he just grabbing books where he
was just grabbing
books and reading them at every
opportunity he could get.
Um,
uh,
and um,
yeah,
basically that's basically the story.
Do we know anything about his further
education as he got a little bit older?
Uh,
I don't know anything about his further
education and I don't think he was
university educated.
Um,
he obviously went on to get a law
degree,
but in those days,
getting a law degree was you clerked
under a lawyer and then,
um,
you hung out your shingle,
right?
Uh,
uh,
so,
as far as formal education is concerned,
uh,
he didn't have very much of that.
Yeah.
Was his real ambition at first
to be a lawyer?
Uh,
I don't know whether he had a real
ambition at first.
I mean,
you know,
he,
he had a lot of other kinds of more
frontier oriented jobs.
Right.
That's how he got the nickname,
the rail splitter.
I'm working on the rivers,
uh,
and uh,
and those sorts of things.
And so,
um,
I think he just sort of fell into a law.
Yeah.
So he's alone,
but eventually,
I mean,
eventually politics became his passion.
Yeah.
So he's a lawyer and then politics
became his passion.
Yeah.
I would say
two are interrelated because remember at
that time,
uh,
um,
many of your politicians,
if not most of your politicians,
uh,
we're either came through the military
or through the profession of law.
Yeah.
Was there a seminal moment for him that
he realized this is when and why I have
to get into politics?
Uh,
no,
I don't think so.
I don't think so,
uh,
you know,
it's like a life happens and
opportunities open and you take
advantage of them.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
he,
I had a legal profession,
uh,
in Illinois and then he was elected to
the Illinois legislature,
uh,
eventually elected to the House of
Representatives,
uh,
for a short time,
and um,
and became very prominent,
uh,
in the Illinois Whig Party.
Yeah.
What were his politics like in time and
what was the whig party like?
Okay,
well this is one of the places,
if,
if you,
um,
look at the two parties,
ideologically at that time it was the
whigs versus the Democrats and the wigs
or the intervention intervention is
party.
Uh,
the wigs were in favor of high
protective tariffs.
They were in favor of spending a lot of
money,
government money on internal
improvements,
what we call infrastructure today,
uh,
and they were in favor of a nationally
chartered bank and a lot of these
policies were the outgrowth of one of
the most prominent wig leaders,
Henry Clay and what he termed as
American system.
Whereas by this time,
the Democratic Party had become the
party of a laissez faire,
a low tariffs,
getting rid of the national bank and in
fact actually trying to divorce
government from any relationship with
banks,
um,
and at least trying to keep the federal
government out of funding internal
improvement.
Yeah.
That,
that's very interesting to me because in
a modern sense,
that seems to be bit of a reversal on
where we're at right now.
Was,
was Lincoln really in line with.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
he really admired Henry Clay.
Henry Clay,
what was his hero?
Uh,
and he,
uh,
he supported all of those policies down
the line when he was in,
uh,
the state legislature in Illinois.
He was crucial and passing a very
expensive internal improvements program
in Illinois that subsequently almost
drove the state into bankruptcy,
a financing of canals and railroads.
So fiscally at the time he was,
he was spending a lot and did the,
the infrastructure deal actually makes
sense.
Uh,
well,
I'm uh,
no,
in other words,
if,
if what happened is that the states went
through sort of two phases in terms of
infrastructure.
The first phase was canal building and
the second phase was railroads.
These are often referred to as phases of
the transportation revolution.
During that period,
uh,
the canal building or GE was actually
set off by a New York building,
the Erie Canal,
which is one of the few examples of a
socialist enterprise that actually made
a profit.
And so this inspired a lot of other
states to build canals,
almost all of which lost money and
created financial problems for the
states that,
uh,
built them,
which is suggest that they were not
economically justified.
Uh,
and then as a result of the state's
losing so much money on the canals,
um,
initially they were heavily involved in
railroads and they continue to subsidize
the railroads,
but at least,
uh,
by the 18,
40 [inaudible] and 18 fifties,
they weren't owning outright the
railroads the way they had owned
outright the canals.
And therefore,
um,
uh,
even the,
the,
there was a little bit too much railroad
expansion,
a subsidized by the government,
but it wasn't as significant as the
problems created by the canal building.
Interesting.
Because this is a part of Lincoln that I
don't,
you know,
we mostly think about the civil war and
freeing the slaves,
but the economic party sort of
interesting.
What do you think has sort of overriding
economic policy was because it sounds
like it was,
it was.
Well,
he carried this policy into the
presidency.
The first,
a subsidized transcontinental railroads
were during Lincoln's administration
during the civil war,
and that resulted in many other trans
continentals and being subsidized by the
national government and a whole bunch of
a pork barrel legislation and in the
post civil war period,
and a lot of scandals,
corruption involved as well.
So,
um,
uh,
so,
so his economic views continued
throughout his entire career.
And these were,
this was the main dividing line between
the two policies to the,
between the two political parties,
uh,
because up until the civil war,
both political parties tied to straddle
the issue of slavery,
so they would both be national parties.
Um,
so they tried to keep it out as best
they could out of the political arena.
When did he start talking about slavery?
Really?
I mean,
when he was in the Illinois legislature.
No,
he doesn't really start talking about
slavery.
Um,
he,
uh,
he had a visceral dislike of slavery,
from his youth,
but he didn't really start talking about
slavery until,
um,
after the Kansas Nebraska Act.
And slavery becomes a,
a prominent issue and it causes a,
the death of the whig party,
um,
and the collapse of the,
uh,
of the wake park.
Can you explain that a little bit more?
Why,
why that actually?
Yeah.
Well,
see both parties initially try to
straddle the slavery issue,
but as,
as it evolves over time,
um,
the whig party being more
interventionists tends to be stronger in
New England.
I'm a,
whereas the Democratic Party tending to
be non intervention is,
tends to be stronger in the south and
the West.
And so,
uh,
the both parties feel the strain between
northern and southern Democrats,
northern and southern wigs,
but the whig party is actually blown
apart by that strain after,
uh,
the Kansas Nebraska Act.
And one issue that causes the demise of
the whig party a is slavery.
So you have the split between northern
whigs in southern wigs.
Um,
and then also another issue that comes
to the fore during that period is
immigration.
Um,
uh,
there is a,
a nativist movement,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
some,
wigs,
uh,
end up embracing.
And that also is a,
plays a role in the,
in the demise of the whig party.
What was his policy on?
Well,
actually Lincoln was fairly good on
that.
I mean,
he was,
in other words,
there was a debate within the councils
of the Republican Party about,
um,
you know,
between those who were more nativist and
who,
those who are less nativist and Lincoln
was definitely on the side of the one he
didn't want.
He didn't want the Republican Party to
be able to take a,
a platform stand on,
on nativism opposing,
uh,
immigration or actually they,
they,
they weren't proposing restrictions on
immigration so much as restrictions on
acquiring citizenship.
So when the whig party fell apart and
then basically the remnants became the
Republican Party.
What,
what,
what was that like,
like where did they literally just.
Well,
actually the people are,
well initially,
initially the Republican Party as a
coalition of antislavery wigs and
antislavery Democrats.
So it,
um,
it's exclusively a sectional party.
It's almost exclusively.
So,
just to be really clear on that though.
So the Republican Party actually was the
original antislavery party.
It was taking from both sides,
and we're taking,
now we need to be clear about this term
antislavery,
um,
uh,
because being antislavery was,
was a,
a broad tent.
I'm at one extreme where the
abolitionists,
um,
and at least in America,
the term abolitionists refers to a
antislavery,
a advocates who favor immediate
emancipation of all slaves and full
political rights for all African
Americans.
So,
um,
there's a whole range of antislavery,
uh,
positions.
And so the Republican Party,
uh,
the abolitionists are always a minority
and the Republican Party,
I'm succeeds where the abolitionists
don't succeed by reducing antislavery to
its lowest common denominator,
essentially one issue which is opposing
the spread of slavery into the
territories.
And so you have a,
and again,
the Kansas Nebraska Act,
uh,
in which,
Kansas and Nebraska were opened to
slavery,
uh,
in violation of the Missouri compromise
is what sort of inspires this,
a concern among antislavery northerners.
So just to,
just to be clear,
at the beginning of the civil war,
there are a lot of Democrats involved in
former Democrats involved in the
Republican Party.
Lincoln's secretary of State Solomon
chases a former Democrat,
um,
several Republican governors,
uh,
and send it,
pardon me,
yet,
Republican senators and governors are
former Republican.
So in Lincoln's election,
that Republican party has to sort of
straddle these economic issues to keep
both sides of the coalition Together.
Where did he fall when,
when he was running for president,
where did he fall on that scale of
abolitionists?
To what,
what would you call you?
Call that other group.
They were sort of,
well,
they're just a,
they're just anti slavery and,
um,
but what,
what that approach that they had,
what would you refer to?
Is that pragmatic or what did they base?
It was a.
well,
gradualist pragmatic.
Basically,
again,
this is where Lincoln follows Henry
Clay.
Henry clay was a favorite.
W W was in favor of colonization in
other words,
uh,
not just,
having a,
a plan of perhaps compensated
emancipation,
um,
in which freed slaves,
are,
uh,
move to back to Africa.
And Lincoln was a big advocate of
colonization.
And in fact,
he continues to pursue colonization.
Um,
even after the outbreak of the civil
war.
Um,
by the end of the civil war,
he's probably given up on that,
but during the civil war,
uh,
he,
sponsored one,
a disastrous attempt at colonization in
Haiti,
uh,
that,
um,
it just didn't work.
What happened?
Well,
what happened is that they,
they,
they got the,
um,
I'm a little bit hazy on the details
but,
but um,
some land was acquired in Haiti and they
got some African Americans who agreed to
move there and then it was not just
economically unviable,
but,
uh,
does had problems with disease.
And so the whole colony collapse.
In other words,
he wanted to do it.
He was,
he wanted to push it in Latin America,
something similar to Liberia.
I'm in,
I'm in Africa,
which also was also a colonization,
skiing a set up by the American
Colonization Society of which Henry Clay
was a participant.
Right.
So there's a couple of interesting
things there.
So you referenced that the Whig Party
itself had a sort of internal conflict
between their northern representatives
and that would be someone like Abraham
Lincoln had their southern.
If you are a local representative in the
legislature in Illinois,
did it ever come up to talk about,
I mean,
why would slavery even really,
it was only within the national
discussion,
right?
Like was it something that people were
actually voting on in any way or not at
the state level?
No,
I'm.
Th,
they're hard to think of party politics
into 2018 lens without everything being
a national and everybody affected by
every little thing.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
the only sense in which it was it the
only sense in which the state you got
involved at the state level was with
respect to the fugitive slave law.
So if you look at the history of
slavery,
there's always this tension between free
states and slave states,
um,
even at the constitutional convention,
uh,
but it,
um,
is usually kept below the surface except
during,
uh,
these,
instances where it,
where it erupts and then it's resolved.
So you first have a Missouri coming in
as a slave state,
which leads to the Missouri compromise
and then,
uh,
things calmed down and then you have the
tariff issue,
which is partially driven by South
Carolina slave.
Um,
and then you have a things calming down
with the annexation of Texas and
California coming in as a state.
Slavery becomes a big issue again.
Um,
and it's partially,
um,
uh,
I'm,
I'm calmed down by the compromise of
1850 and then after that you'll have the
Kansas Nebraska act.
And then,
uh,
then there's no calming it down anymore.
And the compromise of 1850 is
responsible.
Part of the,
part of what southerners got out of the
compromise of 1850 or more precisely
slaveholders was the slave,
was the fugitive slave act of 1850.
I'm now one of the,
one of the constitutional deals,
I mean,
right in the constitution,
there's a fugitive slave provision in
which,
um,
it's the obligation of free states to
return runaway slaves.
And The Washington administration
actually passed the first fugitive slave
act.
But the fugitive slave act of 1850 was
one of the most draconian laws that
Congress ever enacted.
And,
um,
uh,
in other words,
it set up a,
a bureaucracy of commissioners who would
hear,
um,
uh,
cases of fugitive slaves.
They got $5 if they decided that,
uh,
that the,
a person wasn't a slave and $10,
if they decided it was a sleigh,
uh,
they,
um,
the slave had no right to represent j
station.
I'm a jury trial.
No right to testify.
The legislature and,
uh,
the uh,
the commissioners could,
um,
uh,
require the cooperation of individuals,
um,
uh,
to apprehend runaways.
And if you violated a that you could
face a jail sentence,
$1,000
fine,
a $1,000
civil penalties for each escaped slave.
So it was pretty.
So many of your northern states began
before this,
but began after this passing what were
called personal liberty laws.
I'm trying to make sure that state
officials did not participate in the
apprehension and return of runaways.
And so that's,
that's,
that's the,
that's the big slavery issue in northern
states.
Yeah.
It sounds like such a crazy thing
because they were incentivizing the
northern states that may not have wanted
to send the slaves back.
They were literally financially
incentivizing and then as you were
saying,
there were other people,
there were just citizens that were going
out there,
but also also also made it easier to
engage in kidnapping.
I'm free blacks.
Yeah,
bringing them south.
Who was fighting this the most?
I mean,
I would imagine there must've been some
states rights people in the north that
maybe you didn't even care about slavery
per se,
but must've said you can't tell what
this is.
This is one of the things after the
compromise of 1850 that brings slavery,
starts pushing it to the forefront.
And of course this is when a heli,
Elliot,
a uncle Tom's cabin,
um,
Henry beat.
What's her first name?
I'm drawing a blank up.
It'll pop up and say I'm a Harriet
Beecher stowe rights uncle.
Tom's cabin,
which becomes a best seller and it's
about the fugitive slave issues.
So it sensitizes a lot of northerners to
the fugitive slave a question.
And so a Illinois doesn't pass it a
personal liberty law because southern
Illinois is actually settled by,
um,
uh,
from the southern,
the eastern southern states,
uh,
but some of your other states like
Pennsylvania,
uh,
and states further north do pass
personal liberty laws as a result of
either before the fugitive slave act or
after the fugitive slave act.
So before we get directly into the
presidency and the war,
is there anything else we need to know
about Lincoln's politics at the time or
what else was influencing him besides
obviously there were states' rights
issues,
there was obviously the slavery issue.
Uh,
it,
was there anything else that we think of
as really the moments that kind of
shaped him before the president?
I think,
I think we've,
I think we've covered the important
issue.
Those are the big ones.
Okay.
So he runs for president.
What do we need to know about that
platform?
Well,
as I say,
it tries to paper over the difference
between former Democrats informer wigs.
It has a,
it has a plank about,
um,
uh,
about the tariff,
that,
uh,
can be interpreted differently.
Uh,
but the primary,
a plank is a,
his opposition to the spread of slavery
into any more territories.
Uh,
and uh,
what's interesting about that plank is
that it's essentially that plank has
essentially been declared
unconstitutional by the Supreme Court in
the dred Scott decision in the dred
Scott decision.
The Supreme Court says that I'm,
uh,
has,
the territories are the common property
of both nor northerners and southerners,
and therefore the national government
cannot restrict the property rights of
southerners when they move into the
territories by preventing them from
bringing their slaves.
So that,
so you have,
you have a platform plank that was,
that was literally unconstitutional,
a declared unconstitutional.
I mean,
most Supreme Court,
uh,
most,
legal scholars today think it was a very
bad decision,
but yes,
it was,
had been declared unconstitutional.
What do we need to know about the tenor
of the political infighting at that
time?
You know,
these days,
everyone always says,
never has never been worse.
Everyone's meaner than ever before.
And you know,
trump's tweeting this and all that.
But,
uh,
there were some pretty serious fighting.
Okay?
And those kinds of claims or are
exaggerated,
I mean,
you,
you can find a campaign rhetoric and
campaign literature that,
uh,
if not vicious version of verges on
being vicious throughout this,
the period leading up to the civil war.
I wouldn't say that the civil war,
uh,
are the 1860 election is particularly
unique in that respect.
Um,
but what happens is that you end up
having a four candidates,
a Lincoln as the candidate of the
Republican Party,
um,
and then the Democratic Party splits.
So you have Stephen Douglas as the
candidate of the northern Democrats.
I'm John Breckinridge is the candidate
of the southern,
uh,
Democrats.
And then some of your,
um,
uh,
upper tiers,
former southern wigs,
um,
form a constitutional union party.
So to oversimplify only a little,
it becomes really to elections and
election between Lincoln and Douglas in
the north and in an election between
Breckenridge and John Bell and the
Constitutional Union Party in the south.
Yeah.
So the next obvious segue is the Lincoln
Douglas Debates,
right?
That's.
No,
that's before the 18,
60 election.
It was for that election though.
No,
no,
no.
This is,
remember this,
I'm,
when I'm,
senators are still chosen by the state
legislature.
Uh,
so that's one of the things that makes a
debate unique because it's the 1858
Senate election in Illinois.
The legislature is going to choose who
is going to be the senator,
but the Republican candidate is,
is Lincoln,
the Democratic candidate is douglas and
then they go around and have these
debates,
um,
at various throughout Illinois.
That's funny.
I mean,
I like to think that I know a lot about
this stuff.
I had no idea that,
that wasn't on the national scale
because they did run against each other
just two years later,
two years later.
So this actually propels Lincoln into
the forefront of potential candidates
for the Republican nomination in 1860,
even though the legislature chooses
douglass as an Illinois senator.
So when I want you to explain what the
Lincoln Douglas debates are and why
there's such a richness there,
but was nothing like this even done
before that when we,
everyone talks about it like it was so
revolutionary or we so desperately could
use it these days.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't go so far as say it nothing
like it,
but in terms of how extensive it was and
the draw,
it was unprecedented.
Uh,
can you explain the basic tenants of
sort of how it would work?
Um,
well,
basically they picked out various
locations in Illinois,
I forget the number of debates and they
would travel there and then they would,
um,
a face off each other and the big issue
with slavery and Lincoln,
his position was prohibiting slavery.
The extension of slavery into the
territory's Douglass,
his position he was trying,
he was,
the Democratic Party hadn't split,
so he was trying to maintain the unity
of the Democratic Party.
So,
uh,
his position is known as popular
sovereignty and his view was that,
um,
uh,
we leave the territory's open and then
let people in the territory's decide
whether it's going to be a slave
territory or a free territory,
but that creates a certain amount of
ambiguity because when did I get to
decide?
Do they only get to the side?
I'm a,
at the time of statehood,
I'm also a,
uh,
if they decide before statehood,
aren't they violating the dred Scott
Decision?
So,
so that was,
but there was also a racial element to
the debates.
Um,
because you brought,
you brought up the issue of viciousness
in the campaigns.
I'm,
the attempt is to paint Lincoln as an
advocate of,
um,
racial amalgamation because even in the
north,
uh,
despite the northern states being free
states,
um,
in most of the northern states,
African Americans face legal disability,
um,
uh,
and uh,
and significant social discrimination.
So,
so,
so at this time a Lincoln would make the
distinction between,
um,
between a civil equality,
political equality and social equality
and civil equality is being means being
equal.
Before the law,
political equality would involve giving
African Americans the right to vote and
then we know it.
Social equality is about.
So his position at this time,
he did not advocate political equality
was not in favor of giving
African-americans.
Right.
So,
but he was firmly in favor of civil
equality and that's where he and Douglas
Different.
What was that
part?
Totally pragmatic in that he felt if he
said,
well,
I am,
it might have been programmatic,
but remember he,
he's,
uh,
as I said he was,
he was in favor of colonization,
[inaudible],
uh,
even if he,
even when he began to entertain views of
political equality for pragmatic
reasons,
not politically,
but for pragmatic reasons.
He wasn't sure if the country was ready.
Um,
in other words,
he would use arguments which I think are
sincere,
that,
um,
you know,
uh,
that the two races are not going to be
comfortable living together and that it
would be better off for African
Americans once free to,
uh,
move elsewhere.
Yeah.
Now he,
eventually,
he eventually dropped that and
eventually by the end of his life was a
favoring a limited franchise for a freed
African Americans in Louisiana.
So his ideas are changing.
They're progressing.
Yeah.
That's what's interesting is that there
is an evolution here,
which really we find out really in the
presidency.
Did the abolitionists basically hate him
at that point?
I mean,
did they think he was sort of a sellout
or that he just because he was doing the
pragmatic thing?
Yes,
abolitionists did.
Some abolitionists did ever.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
so there was still,
there had been before the creation of
the Republican party,
there had been the liberty party in the
free soil party,
which were slightly broader antislavery
coalitions,
but minor minor parties and there still
was a radical abolitionist party that
ran in 1860,
but it garnered very,
very,
a few votes
[inaudible].
Okay.
So we started touching them,
the beginnings of the election.
So basically for candidates running,
right,
because of the split in the Democratic
Party.
What else do we have to know before he
gets elected that,
that happened?
That's pretty much it.
I mean,
he didn't win the popular vote,
but even if you combine the vote of all
the other candidates,
he still would have won the electoral
college.
Right.
Interesting.
So what was the beginning of his
presidency?
Right?
Uh,
well,
um,
the beginning of his is a dominated by
the,
a succession of the deep south.
So soon after he was inaugurated,
um,
well after he's elected,
the deep south secedes with South
Carolina being the first state,
and then you have the cotton states,
I'm succeeding was even inaugurated now.
No,
that was right after the election is
incredible by the way.
One interesting detail that,
um,
a lot of people are unaware of and South
Carolina's ordinance of succession and
they're the first state.
They're the,
they're the most firebrand of all the,
a secessionist,
um,
uh,
in their ordinance of secession.
Um,
they do not,
uh,
the,
the issue they give the largest play too
in terms of justifying secession is not
Lincoln's election,
but northern failure to comply with the
fugitive slave clause of the
constitution.
Now,
partially that's a rhetorical ploy
because it allows them to argue that the
northerners,
um,
ha ha had divided the constitutional
contract first,
but it also reflects a deep concern
about I'm a fugitive slaves.
And,
and one of the,
one of the points that I make in my book
is that I think most historians have
underestimated the economic significance
of the,
of the fugitive slave issue in terms of
bringing on succession.
And maybe we can get to that.
No,
I,
I do want to get to that.
So,
um,
so,
so you have the deep south seceding and
they're seizing all of the US military
basis except for a few that are holding
out and the prominent one that's holding
out his fort sumpter and Charleston
harbor.
Uh,
so James Buchanan has to deal with this.
He's the lame duck president.
He tries to reinforce a sumpter and a
South Carolina fires on the ship.
And so,
but the garrison is still there when
Lincoln,
it becomes president.
So that's the big issue that's
dominating a Lincoln's presidency is
what do you,
what do you do about Fort Sumpter?
And I'm a Lincoln.
Um,
you know,
he's getting all kinds of advice.
Uh,
some people want him to try to.
I'm back down on the Republican position
about slavery in the territories,
but he absolutely refuses to do so.
I mean,
he's,
he has agreed to enforce the fugitive
slave act as president,
so this is the only antislavery issue
and he decides to hang onto it.
Um,
and uh,
someone,
a more aggressive policy,
someone the more passive policy,
basically I'm Lincoln essentially
follows Buchanan's policy,
although Buchanan gets a lot of
criticism you that and what happens is
we'll Buchanan's policy being what being
a,
trying to reinforce the fort but not
using military force to,
um,
to,
to uh,
um,
hold on to the fort.
Gotcha.
All right.
So,
uh,
Lincoln sends 'em reinforcements and
supplies to the Fort,
uh,
telling the uh,
South Carolina that he's doing.
So by this time the confederacy is
formed,
the confederacy fires on Fort Sumpter,
right?
And,
and that's the,
that's the nine slash 11 of the civil
war.
It polarizes both sides of it.
Polarizes northerners because up until
this time,
there are a lot of northern resou
saying,
well,
we should let the south going piece.
Many of them think,
well,
if we let them go and piece,
they'll come back.
Um,
and at the time of Lincoln's
inauguration,
there's still more slave states in the
union then out of the union.
Um,
but Lincoln responds to the firing on
Fort Sumpter by calling out troops and
immediately Virginia,
North Carolina,
Tennessee and Arkansas all joined the
confederacy.
So it,
it,
it's the great divide.
Um,
with a stroke of the pen,
he's,
he's doubled the size and the material
resources of the confederacy.
Yeah.
What do we know about his thought
process at the time?
Well,
he really ready for the fallout that was
gonna happen.
Um,
yes and no.
And then the escalation.
Yes and no.
Let me back up a little and explain why
he had to do this.
All right,
uh,
why it was politically necessary to do
this.
Um,
many of your abolitionists,
particularly William Lloyd Garrison,
who is one of my heroes who was
advocated immediate emancipation,
full political rights for all African
Americans.
He was also a pacifist.
I'm an anarchist,
a classical liberal and favor of free
trade,
free labor,
his opposition to slavery.
A lot of the radical abolitionist framed
it as man stealing.
Um,
and,
you know,
in terms of a property rights and he was
also in favor of northern secession from
the union because he saw the
constitution as a pro slavery document.
Uh,
he,
um,
denounced the,
uh,
constitution.
I'm a publicly burned a copy and on the
masthead of his,
of his paper that liberate or no union
with slave holders.
I'm grace throughout,
uh,
from 18,
31 on to the civil war.
And,
and this was true of many of your most
radical abolitionists.
So basically what you're abolitionists
and one of the reasons they were so
unpopular is because they were saying
you can't have antislavery and union.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
people are committed to the union,
right?
So they're not happy about the
Appalachian.
The Republican Party,
by reducing the antislavery issue to its
lowest common denominator in the
territory's is telling the public,
you can have a antislavery in union.
Alright,
well,
once the unions threatened,
the Republican Party is going to have to
suppress succession or face political
oblivion.
And in fact,
even if Stephen Douglas had been elected
president,
he's an old hard line Jacksonian if he
had been elected president and the south
had still succeeded.
Now that's not very likely,
but if he had been elected president and
the staff,
it's succeeded,
he probably would have moved a military
force against the south even faster than
Lincoln
[inaudible].
It's,
it's so interesting because I think one
of the themes as we do this whole week
is looking at these people through 2018
lens and when you hear that somebody
didn't want full rights for people but
wanted to free them or they couldn't
vote or some of the other issues you're
talking about.
And yet at the same time you're saying,
but the abolition is actually weren't
that popular,
right?
It's like to give,
to view these people through our lens
today is,
is really,
it's a very slippery slope because
Lincoln had to do some things that
perhaps,
uh,
in our lens now would have been viewed
as very unfair to the African American.
And there he was.
So.
Okay.
So the,
the war begins and he said he's a new
president at war.
A,
who is he getting advice from?
Were like,
did he really understand how to.
Okay.
Well,
the other part of the answer to your
question is that I'm a Lincoln and many
of the Republicans in many northerners
in general underestimated,
um,
the enthusiasm for succession on the
part of southerners.
They believed,
initially believed that it was a
southern elite of slaveholders,
almost a conspiracy that had brought
about succession and that,
um,
and that's why they weren't prepared for
the extent of the resistance of a
southerners.
Uh,
once Lincoln,
uh,
calls out troops.
And so once he calls out troops,
then,
then you have the problem of managing
the war.
So there was really,
he could have done at
that point,
even if even if there were voices,
even if he internally felt,
well,
maybe we could just let them go,
or if he had voices around him that were
saying,
Oh,
you know,
seed,
it was too late,
really,
right.
Yep.
Politically,
politically.
I mean,
by that time I'm in the north,
at least not in the deep south,
but in the North Liberty in union had
become mystically identify as
inseparable.
Uh,
and uh,
and so that's,
um,
and,
and in fact,
right,
this leads to the question of,
uh,
the,
a more basic question of what caused the
civil war.
Right?
And there's now a current trend to argue
that slavery caused the civil war and
not only that caused the civil war,
but it was all about slavery.
Uh,
and that in fact,
slavery,
um,
the entire history of the union up until
that point is all about slavery.
You disagree with it?
I just get away.
I think that asking what caused the
civil war is the wrong question.
And even some of your new abolitionists,
historians like Ken Stamp and Eric Foner
have pointed out that they're really two
separate questions.
Why does the sow seed and why does the
North refused to let the south go?
And the answer to the first question is
definitely slavery.
I mean,
the evidence is overwhelming for that.
There's probably hardly any historical
causal explanation at that level of
abstraction for which the evidence is
more overwhelming.
So the south secedes in order to protect
slavery.
Okay,
so that's easy,
but I'm ending.
Slavery is not what motivates the north,
what motivates the north is preserving
the union.
And in fact,
Lincoln,
I'm,
uh,
in the Er before the firing on Fort
sumpter endorses a original 13th
amendment which has not passed in which
he's still holding to the position of
opposing the extension of slavery in the
territories.
But this new amendment would protect
slavery in the existing slave states and
be unamendable in the early days of the
war.
Uh,
some of your union commanders were
returning runaway slaves.
So,
um,
so the,
so,
so the war from the union perspective,
the suppression of succession is
designed to preserve the union.
And Lincoln even later says,
if he could preserve the union by
freeing all the slaves,
he'll do that.
If he could preserve the union by
framing some none of the slaves,
he'll do that.
If he can preserve the union by freeing
some and leaving others enslaved,
he would do that.
What was his real belief in the union
based in did he,
did he just truly believed that we had
to remain one country otherwise would be
perpetual
war?
Is that.
Yeah.
He thought that the disillusion of the
union would lead to anarchy.
Yeah.
It's interesting because now one of the
things that's one of the things that's
interesting about historians is the,
the,
even historians who don't seem to be
explicitly nationalist than nationalist
bias with which they,
um,
approach that issue.
Uh,
so,
uh,
for instance,
the US,
I had made several attempts to an ex
Canada,
um,
in the early history,
uh,
first during the American revolution,
then during the war of 18,
12,
and then,
uh,
between and after those events,
by sponsoring the kinds of a
revolutionary movements that,
uh,
brought Texas into the union.
All right.
If any of those had succeeded
historians,
would it be writing great historians
would be writing the history of North
America as if this was an inevitable in
any other result would have been
catastrophic.
Um,
my view is that the north,
uh,
that the North American continent has
gotten along fine with,
to Anglo American republics.
If it had been three or more history
would have been different,
but would have been,
it wouldn't have been catastrophic,
different.
And,
and speaking of the example of Canada,
you know,
when Canada was looking at the,
at this session of the peaceful
succession of Quebec,
its population was about the same size
as the union at the time and the
population of Quebec was greater than
the Gulf coast confederacy that
initially succeeded and slightly less
than the confederacy once a Lincoln had
called out troops.
Did Lincoln have any advisors or anyone
close to him at the time that was just
saying,
forget this,
you know,
just let them go.
No,
we're going to do,
we live by our laws here.
So he really,
well,
there were some,
um,
there were some newspaper editors prior
to Fort Sumpter who were in favor of a
peaceful succession and letting us out
south,
at least temporarily go in peace.
Uh,
there was even a secessionist movement,
uh,
in New York City,
but I'm meaning they wanted New York
City to see.
See?
Yeah.
Even though geographically you've got
really make any sense.
And uh,
um,
and uh,
uh,
Lincoln's,
um,
I'm a secretary of state,
toyed with the idea provoking a war with
Great Britain in order to bring
everybody a steward.
I'm back together,
but,
um,
but nobody really,
at least within Republican Council's
excepted,
um,
uh,
once,
especially after Fort Sumpter,
uh,
the preservation of the union a becomes
upper most God,
so most of his presidency,
which obviously was cut short and we'll
get to that shortly.
Um,
was,
uh,
it was about the civil war is there.
What else do we have to know?
How sort of towards the end of the war,
what other decisions did he make that
were sort of pivotal?
Um,
well,
he starts a reconstruction program,
uh,
which,
um,
is relatively lenient,
compared to the congressional
reconstruction,
uh,
that is eventually implemented after a
whole Lincoln's assassination.
Limited in what regard?
I'm lenient in terms of allowing white
southerners a free hand in terms of,
of,
uh,
as long as they allow,
had abolished slavery of reentering a,
the union.
And how is that different than what
happened?
Well,
basically,
um,
uh,
well,
this is a complicated story.
I'm going to try and make it really
simple.
Okay.
You have this first phase presidential
reconstruction which Lincoln initiates
and then becomes really lenient under
his,
um,
uh,
a successor,
Andrew Johnson who was from Tennessee.
I'm a very racist,
um,
but antislavery southerner.
Um,
and what happens is that the southern
states essentially set up,
I'm under a,
um,
uh,
a lot of the former confederate
leadership,
an apartheid regime with black codes
that are very restrictive,
uh,
on the,
on the activities of the freed African
Americans and this outrageous,
um,
northern republicans.
And so you have a period of
congressional reconstruction where none
of these governments are there.
They're all disbanded.
You have military occupation,
and then you have the creation of new
Republican governments in which a lot of
southerners are disenfranchised and
African Americans are given voting
rights.
And so you have a period of Republican
regimes,
I'm in the south,
and then that creates the resistance of
organizations like the Ku Klux Klan and
other violent organizations.
And uh,
by 18,
76 northerners have gotten tired of
trying to maintain these regimes with
military occupation.
And so you have what's euphemistically
referred to as redemption where you have
the restoration of a,
of white rule,
um,
throughout the,
uh,
former slave states.
Yeah.
So I,
it's just hard to imagine what a messy
time it would've been.
Yeah.
During those years,
just healing all those wounds,
literally family members having killed
each other,
especially in your border states like
Kentucky and Missouri.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's really just hard to imagine what it
was like.
So the north obviously wins does not
succeed.
The union is maintained,
uh,
what was happening just in the weeks
leading up to his assassination?
Well,
Lisa rendered,
um,
a same month,
I believe.
And so it was clear that,
um,
it,
it's,
it's clear that the,
that the confederacy has lost the war.
Um,
uh,
and,
you have the passage of the 13th
amendment,
uh,
by Congress.
It still has to be ratified by the
states,
um,
a abolishing slavery,
uh,
and,
those are the,
most,
the two most important,
uh,
events leading up.
Yeah,
through the end of the war.
So to talk about the assassination for a
little bit,
I mean obviously just from everything
we're talking about it and it was
wartime and everything else.
Obviously,
you know,
tensions were high and all that.
Was there any reason to believe that
anything like this was gonna Happen?
I know that may sound like a very open
question,
but you know,
like we're,
we're there as attempt attack
assassination attempts.
Before that,
anything,
I was always concerned about Lincoln
being assassinated,
particularly at the outset of the war.
Uh,
I mean,
pardon me at the outset of his
administration.
So when he initially comes into
Washington,
um,
he comes in disguised because of concern
about,
uh,
an assassination of rumored
assassination attempts.
And then during the inauguration,
um,
uh,
you have,
a sharp shooters.
I'm stationed at the tops of buildings
and,
um,
uh,
and other provisions made by General
Winfield Scott to make sure that there
is no assassination attempt because
remember,
Washington DC is south of Maryland.
Maryland is a slave state.
Um,
it's a slave state that doesn't succeed
only partially because of union military
force interfering with elections and
throwing secessionists I'm in jail and
Baltimore,
uh,
is at least at the outset of the war is
a pro southern,
um,
hotbed.
Uh,
so there were concerns.
Yeah.
Uh,
but we don't have the secret service.
In fact,
the secret service has created during
the civil war,
mainly to track down counterfeiters.
It's one of the many government agencies
that we've come to.
All love emerges during the civil war.
That's why I started to track down
counterfeiters.
Now it's clearly gone beyond that scope
these days,
but that's a whole other topic.
So I assume that the day,
I mean,
if we had to look at Lincoln the morning
he woke up before he went to the
theater,
he had to have been feeling pretty good
about things.
I mean,
he had to be accomplished.
The thing that was most important to
him,
and he certainly was feeling relieved.
Yeah.
What should we talk about related to the
assassination?
Um,
well,
give me the basics for people.
Well,
I,
I don't.
I mean there's now evidence that there
was more involvement of a confederate,
um,
counter intelligence,
whatever you wanna call it.
Then we previously.
In other words,
it wasn't entirely.
I'm John Wilkes booth and,
and his confederates.
Is there hard evidence on that?
Yeah,
they,
I've heard little things.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
um,
uh,
but I don't really have a lot to say
about,
about the assassination of Lincoln.
I'm in so far as.
Okay,
here.
One of the big debates is if Lincoln
hadn't been assassinated,
would he have continued,
um,
his lenient policy towards,
uh,
the southern states and um,
and I go along with the historians who
say no,
that he was trying.
I'm leniency in order to try to
reestablish the whig party.
I'm in the south,
but it wasn't turning out that way.
And a congressional reconstruction may
not have been quite as harsh under
Lincoln,
um,
as it turned out to be without Lincoln.
Uh,
but,
um,
but Lincoln's views have evolved to the
extent that he would not have been,
uh,
would have been willing to tolerate the
black codes that,
um,
uh,
that the states were setting up,
do you think,
certainly by his second term where he
would've had a freer hand,
he would have done a lot of the things
that would,
that happen during congressional
reconstruction?
Yeah,
that's my speculation.
Yeah.
What was it like after the
assassination?
Well,
it's like any assassination,
you know,
they're,
um,
there,
there is a man hunt.
Um,
there is an attempt to track down the
conspiracy,
uh,
and uh,
you have several conspirators hung
including Mary Serat who,
and there's a lot of controversy about
whether she was actually involved or not
involved and uh,
uh,
so it certainly hardens northern
attitudes.
Uh,
but remember,
was there really a feeling that he was
the one keeping it all together at that
point?
Still are,
or what was the feeling that the war had
been won?
It was,
it was going to be okay either way,
you know,
he was such a symbol of what had
happened.
Um,
I mean,
he,
he had already,
uh,
that's an interesting question.
Um,
in some circles,
um,
he had already become deified but not to
the extent that the assassination dfi.
Um,
so,
uh,
he remember he'd already been elected
for a second term,
so,
so he did not face a significant
political opposition there.
Was there before the fall of Atlanta,
there were,
there,
there because the war dragged on so
long.
Um,
it wasn't always clear that Lincoln
would be renominated by the Republican
Party and there were elements in the
Republican Party,
um,
uh,
who wanted to replace him and rivals who
wanted to replace him.
So,
uh,
a really,
um,
uh,
you,
you have,
you have Andrew Johnson being president,
you know,
for most of Lincoln's second term and
uh,
he's impeached or almost he's impeached
and almost removed,
um,
uh,
from office because of his disagreement
with,
uh,
the Republicans who are in tight control
of Congress because,
uh,
the southern states have been kept out,
are still not in,
um,
except for Tennessee.
Um,
and the slave states that didn't succeed
there.
They're still not,
um,
uh,
in the union or are permitted to have
representatives in Congress so the
Republicans have a free hand
irrespective of whether Lincolns in
office or Andrew Johnson's and office or
grant is an office.
Interesting.
So one of the reasons that I wanted to
do this youtube week was to help frame
things around how politics are right
now.
So to sort of wrap all this up first,
um,
what,
what do you think Lincoln's politics
would be today if you were to try to
take the things that you think he
believed in the most within the sort of
modern context?
Is there a that you can make sense of it
because I see he gets used by everyone
all the time.
Lincoln would have been a Republican for
this.
He would have been a Democrat for this.
Is there a way
like playing that game?
Yeah,
I mean,
things have changed so much.
Um,
uh,
um,
it's really,
it is.
And the context is so different.
Um,
it's really hard to say.
Uh,
one of the,
one of the interesting things about
Lincoln,
and this is one of my,
one of my sort of reservations are
criticisms of Lincoln,
actually criticisms of the people who
deify Lincoln as president is the whig
party,
had this ambivalent attitude in terms of
government versus the presidency.
Um,
they were in favor of a lot of
government intervention,
um,
but at the same time they had emerged in
opposition to Andrew Jackson and his
very vigorous,
often high handed presidency.
So they tended to favor the legislature
as the dominant.
Uh,
I'm a mover,
a forest in the government rather than
the presidency.
And I think Lincoln had imbibed this wig
attitude,
uh,
about,
administration.
And as a result,
I think I'm being a wartime president.
He had to ignore it to a large extent,
but I think that it created some of the
administrative problems that emerged
during Lincoln's presidency.
So I think Lincoln would be,
we'd have very ambivalent feelings about
how powerful the president has become a
within government,
irrespective of what policies are being
implemented.
I will accept.
I will accept that as an answer that
that really was what I was trying to get
to,
not that he would have endorsed this
policy or that policy,
but just his general take on what power
was the opposite of the presidency and,
and things of that nature.
Well,
it's been a pleasure talking to you.
I think.
Are we done?
We're done.
We did the whole hour.
That was a pretty quick.
Our.
Do we miss anything made doing this?
A lot of major things.
Alright.
Give me something major that we missed.
Um,
well I,
uh,
I'll,
I'll give you a couple of things.
One is,
I mean my book,
you didn't mention my book.
Let's talk about your book.
Well I think you've sort of hit on it
there.
Your more critical,
more critical altman in the war then
some of the people who.
Yeah,
the book is a narrative history of the
civil war,
but I have about half a dozen
provocative thesis where I disagree with
trailing views and one of them is that I
argue that if I'm northerners had been
interested in ending slavery rather than
preserving the union,
there is a set of policies they could
have adopted.
I'm allowing,
uh,
the lower south to go in peace,
which would have brought down slavery,
um,
within,
an independent confederacy,
certainly by the turn of the century and
possibly within four years.
Why letting them go would do that.
Um,
well letting them go didn't necessarily
do it.
It just means that you didn't have to
kill 750,000
people in order to bring about the end
of slavery.
In other words,
I think there were,
there is there a set of policies that
could achieve the same goal at less
cost.
Um,
and,
um,
and in other words,
I think you can,
like the,
I was actually t I'm tuned,
don turned onto this alternative by
garrison and the other radical
abolitionist.
In other words,
you can be a rabidly antislavery instill
procession.
Um,
the second,
uh,
important argument I make is,
has to do with,
uh,
the growth of government.
Um,
um,
uh,
I think it's a commonplace observation
that government today is a lot more
powerful and a lot more intrusive than
it was earlier in our history.
And whether you think that's a good
thing or a bad thing,
uh,
there's the question of what changed and
what brought about the change.
So I'm the popular story is that it's
the new deal,
right?
That made the big change and I'm in the
growth of government and I think that's
mistaken,
it's mistaken,
uh,
in part because of the new deal was
essentially a recreation of Woodrow
Wilson's war collectivism.
And the impact of the new deal on
government was dwarfed by the impact of
World War II.
Um,
now there's some elements of truth.
The new deal gives you social security,
um,
and along with Medicare that's become
government's biggest expenditures.
More sophisticated,
um,
commentators would push the change back
to the progressive era in the early 20th
century.
But I'm arguing that the civil war is
the crucial watershed in American
history that prior to that,
prior to the civil war,
the longterm secular trend had at all
levels of government for government to
become smaller,
less intrusive,
less involved in people's lives.
And that the turning point is the civil
war that leaves him with a complex
legacy from the government.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Because during the civil war,
I mean,
national conscription,
I'm a US moves from free to high
protective tariffs,
uh,
the first Western country to do.
So I'm a massive subsidies to railroads,
uh,
for subsidies to higher education
through the land grants.
Um,
and I've already gone over my time.
I could go on.
You got one more,
one more big,
big point that's in the book related.
Yeah.
One more point that's related to
Lincoln.
Um,
uh,
I think that one of the reasons it takes
the union so long to defeat the
confederacy is because of Lincoln's bad
administration of the military.
Uh,
there,
he tended to micromanage.
I'm the war.
Uh,
uh,
like Lyndon Johnson tried to micromanage
the Vietnam war and historians want to
place all of the blame on Lincoln's
generals.
Uh,
whereas I think that really the source
of the problem is Lincoln.
Um,
consider the eastern theater.
All right,
so,
um,
you have a succession of commanders.
Irvin Mcdowell defeated the first bull
run,
replaced my Mcclellan Mcclellan is
almost supplanted by John Pope,
who's defeated the second bull run only
to bring back McClellan then to replace
him with burnside who admitted to him
emitted that he wasn't ready to command
the army and then hooker and then meet
right now normally.
Right?
And this is within a period of two
years,
two,
two and a half years.
Normally this doesn't work.
Earn administrators high marks in terms
of how they're managing things.
Right?
And,
uh,
I think that,
um,
I mean there were problems with all the
generals.
Uh,
the advantage that the generals in the
West had Sherman and grant is they
weren't micromanaged by Lincoln and
therefore they could make their mistakes
early in the war and learn from them.
Yeah.
Well,
I liked that you gave us a complex view.
I mean,
that's really why I wanted to do this,
that,
you know,
we picked certain ones.
Lincoln is one that we all sort of view
in this lens of the perfect being
Lincoln of course.
And of course he did a tremendous amount
of good.
Uh,
but it's interesting hearing what the
little imperfections are a and all sorts
of things.
So on that note,
it has been a pleasure talking to you
and for more,
uh,
Jeffrey Rogers,
I'm all check out his book,
which we're going to link to write down
below.